oh nein gar weiter kommst du noch klar
warum machst du das
ich habe lange überlegt ob ich dieses
video hier machen soll meine gedanken
gingen hin und her ich hab mir gedacht
einerseits ja machten der mega lustig
andererseits so was willst du eigentlich
nicht einem kanal haben aber nach dem in
letzter zeit auch andere youtuber sich
öffentlich zu der thematik geäußert
haben habe ich mir gedacht die zeit ist
gekommen und wir hosten
falls ihr bisher unbekannte land ist die
ladung erst eine youtube
das ist glaube ich die beste freundin
von becker sie wohnen gehabt in den
vereinigten staaten macht täglich videos
und ja ja die videos sind einfach
schmerzhaft denn die liebe zieladresse
auf dem game master film hängen
geblieben wie auch ihre gute freundin
rebecca ring aber das ganze auf eine art
und weise wo man sich wirklich fragt
warum macht man das
ich lese die partikel vor wir haben zb
das wunderbare und auch legendäre video
game master zwingt mich pancake zu essen
hat game master und schwanger von ihm
was ist das für eine geisteskranke
kombination man kombiniert diesen
absoluten drecks trend game master und
macht die ganze sache noch schlimmer die
man zur geisteskrank abgefuckte video
titel hat ganz ehrlich das einzige was
man dazu sagen kann ist alsmann weg zum
titel von vielen sind in aller regel
unter aller sau
aber was passiert eigentlich in den
videos an sich und zweck ziehen wir uns
mal das hochwertige jugend freie und
definitiv qualitativ eindrucksvolle
video game master
als jungfrau ohne pille rey ist ohne
chance wieso nennt man sein video so auf
welchem geist es keinen drogentrips
derzeit ist man sowieso wie hey leute
ich bin es wieder eure lanig war heute
beim briefkasten und wisst ihr was ich
bekommen habe
ich habe einen brief bekommt von
gamestar leute wie ich weiß nicht wie
ich damit umgehen soll
schaut euch einfach die erste zeile der
beschreibung weiter ich will hier
einfach den bleistift eben die augen
jagen wenn ich so eine was hier lese
warum will mich game master als jungfrau
ohne die pille zu nehmen
was soll ich tun alter geht es noch geht
es noch klar die lahn brauchst du hilfe
ihr ganz groß steht hier gm braucht und
wir haben hier eine karte hier ist ein
symbol das soll angeblich komplett sein
ja das ist nicht rot ich weiß nicht wie
leute aber ich bekomme wenn ich mir
anschaue doch den anfang von diesem
video anschauen einfach den eindruck
dass einfach alles egal ist wenn wir uns
die titel anschauen wenn wir uns die
fans anschauen wenn er uns auch
anschauen wie schlecht dabei diese game
master karte gemalt ist dann sieht man
glaube ich recht eindeutig das ziel an
scheinbar jeglichen maßstab für das was
richtig und falsch ist verloren hat und
möglich komplett drauf scheißt was sie
hoch letzte langes klicks bringt wo dann
kommende videos dabei raus wie ey master
wenig geist jungfrau ohne pille muss los
bruder
game master da steht sie geht jetzt erst
hinweis vom game master nachdem sie
selbst in 30 sekunden mit edding auf
einem stück papier gekritzelt kleine
rote wir sehen auch schon woher die gute
freundschaft zur bäckerin kommt so die
eckige skills sind bei beiden einfach
auf allerhöchstem niveau
und da sind das für leute was ist das
für eine absurde kranke rutschte hinter
dem parkhaus irgendwo in amerika und auf
dem schild hat dir und mit kreide dix
geschrieben also dxs englisch für auf
deutsch so krank oder das ist doch
einfach nur krank war
habt ihr auch so das gefühl wenn er
dieses video schaut aus als ob sich
apple denkt du bist auf dem parkplatz
ist wahrscheinlich war und auf dem
parkplatz stehen manchmal natürlich nur
selten und den absoluten extrem und
krisenfällen autos und dann zweiter
punkt leute es ist doch einfach kripo
oder ich finde die art und weise wie sie
redet an diese absoluten psycho titel
oder jetzt dieses bild wie sie so ganz
nahe der kamera steht das ist wirklich
dass das ist krieg iata sie erinnert
mich einfach so an wie habt ihr das
gesehen worauf eben nicht dass jetzt
haben wir sind hier auf jeden fall
richtig
wir müssen halt nur gucken oder sein
könnte wer schaut sich sowas an die
torleute wer zieht sich so was rein und
denkt sich ja aber dass aus keiner
konnte nicht mehr davon sehen wie der
paymaster versucht dich als jungfrau
ohne pillen zu
das schlimme ist wirklich leute der
kanal hat in den letzten 30 tagen 15
tausend abonnenten gemacht wenn
irgendjemand zugriff auf die server von
youtube bitte einmal eine liste dieser
15.000 menschen geben die diesen kanal
abonniert haben damit die sich einzeln
persönlich bei mir entschuldigen können
was denkt ihr ist das von game märkte
wieder blieb mega eklig aus dakar rallye
historique leute bewegen erzählt auch
immer so zu den seltsamsten sachen dass
sie täglich aussehen und vor allem
ständig bei dem schild mutig auf schnee
wie kann man denn da nicht anfangen zu
lachen wenn man so ein video drehte sie
will ernsthaft der kamera verklickert
dass sie einen brief von einer fiktiven
person bekommen hat und erzählt das
ganze welt einfach neben einem
metallschild steht auf dem becher was
ist das für ein kopfgeld
wir haben hier wieder irgendwas habe ich
gleich nach
oh mein gott was ist das
[Applaus]
was ist das für ein verdammt seltsames
video alter
jetzt hat sie in diesem brief ein
geöffnetes kondom gefunden
viel an wie kommst du aus so wie kommt
ein mensch auf so ein video alter peters
ist aber das ist doch einfach nur psycho
oder andere griff auch witzig ist
metallschild auf dem dix steht
sie machen eben diesen brief auf mit der
lehrerin kondo packung ganz ehrlich
leute die menschheit ist verloren
ja das will ich dich ganz gerne fragen
ist ist es ist das dein ernst
ohne scheiß sollte was geht in den
köpfen von rebecca ring und irland vor
wie denken diese menschen so was ist
ihnen wichtig warum machen sie das was
sie machen also ich meinen viel anders
hat auch tausendmal schlimmer als pkw es
ist so ich meine ganz ehrlich mir kann
keiner erzählen dass sie morgens
aufsteht und sich denken hammer geil ich
tue mir heute so als würde der game
master mich wollen macht ein barock
geiles leben
was hat das alles zu bedeuten leute wie
sollte eine kontur platz machen
ja ohne scheiß wieso warum viele warum
tust du uns das all das ist wirklich das
ist ein verhältnis
es kann nicht sein dass ich das auf
youtube wird es kann eigentlich nicht
sein
eine abgemachte am eingang in dieses
kriegs alter als mauer nicht nein
was drin
[Musik]
was das geht ab auf dieser plattform
leute was ist was ist ich bin wirklich
sprachlos leute normalerweise habe ich
bei jedem video über irgendein spruch
dazu oder irgendwas was lustig ist oder
wird ist aber das ist einfach nur
geisteskrank dieser kanal ist einfach
nur krank
es ist einfach krank und dass dieser
kanal ist von 15.000 euro abonniert wohl
den letzten 30 tagen sagt mir da leute
was schief läuft was gehörig schief
es kann nicht 100 schlimme ist es sind
nur solche videos ich finde die videos
an sich sind auch nicht gut gemacht du
diese nicht besonders gut gesprochen die
kameraeinstellung ist nicht so doll ist
es kaum geschnitten und dann einfach so
unfassbar kranke themen game master wem
ihr gurke in die punkt um punkt sieben
kommst du noch klar warum machst du das
bitte auch ich wollte trotz manchmal
ansprechen bei euch sagen bitte falls er
diesen kanal abonniert habt überdenken
teure lebensentscheidung ich habe drüben
jetzt auch ein zufällig vorgeschlagen
das video verlinkt leute garantiert mit
weniger psycho enthalten bleib gesund
bleibt sicher und bleibt weg von tina
enz youtube kanal